peu importe d'où vous en êtes de cette étape
avec votre corps cette gomme est votre
rythme cardiaque et votre Dieu est le Gloria bro
combien de temps avez-vous été un esclave trentenaire ou
est-ce que votre nom Benna
mon père était l'un des plus respectés
à Jérusalem jusqu'à ce que nous soyons trahis  par
mon propre frère
tu sais que nous n'avons rien de mal quelqu'un
réclame du sang crucifié ouais le
monde dans lequel tu vis est faux ses lois
nues farine nue
je ne laisserai pas mon salah impuni pour
ce qu'il nous a fait il y avait un moyen
Giratina
il n'y a pas de loi si ton frère a
reçu de la maison pour le battre et tu vas
vaincre un empire aurait dû rester à l'écart
tu aurais dû me tuer
souviens-toi d'
abord pour finir
aime mourir
mais maintenant élevé a commencé juste
toi